belle programme à suivre ou de bleu là
je trouve ouais ouais ouais on doit
faire quelque chose tous les de france
ont
ainsi beaucoup thomas fallu aller bon
télématin effectivement emmanuel macron
invite à scruter les matins c'est notre
projet
[Musique]
je suis
très conquérant je suis trop parfois
parce que on a le sentiment que j'ai
tout m'a toujours réussi et parce que je
pourrai dans l'énergie très parfois trop
haut trop sucrés les choses
à droite quelqu'un d'autre qu emmanuel
macron qui a fait son temps puisqu'il a
fait cinq ans il avait 5 ans pour nous
montrer ce qui pouvait faire aujourd'hui
à la sortie le bilan c'est que plus de
60% des français ne veulent pas
reconduire et pourtant les gens n'osent
pas parce qu'il y a des gens comme toi
qui disent surtout pas à l'extrême ouest
vers moi je fais ça et voulait pour la
tribune le rassemblement national elle a
bien changé parce que tout le monde peut
évoluer une conférence de presse pour
exposer sa vision de la politique
étrangère mais soudain une femme brandit
une pancarte et se fait violemment
plaqué au sol par le service d'ordre un
bref instant la photo de marine le pen
serrant la main de vladimir poutine en
2017 ressurgi dans cette campagne
la militante et traîné par terre
grasset pas d'agitation moi ça tu
réponds à san bruno une présidente
famelart voilà une une présidente femme
j'aimerais bien voilà une maman des
français quelqu'un qui rassemble qui
protège avec une sensibilité de femme on
sait très bien que les hommes il parle
beaucoup ils font pas tout le temps on
sait bien que les femmes c'est des
mamans c'est une maman qui fait des
choses et les femmes on peut les femmes
les femmes et l'arrivée sur mer on
s'embrasse avant que tu sens bon ganassi
a vraiment a pris moi
je cherche à faire emmanuel macron ses
affaires en fait baisser les pensions
voilà c'est tout ce qu'il souhaite faire
mais moi je ne souhaite pas ce qu'elle
dit c'est votre choix c'est votre bon
vouloir d'autres options tout aussi
raisonnables sont possibles on peut
laisser la retraite à 62 l'écho les
français n'iront jamais jusqu'à 65 ans
donc ils n'auront pas de pension
complète et donc leur leur pension vont
baisser c'était un programme à peu près
à cette heure de la soirée dormait les
enfants mais ce n'est plus diffusé
aujourd'hui à nous les petits bonne nuit
les petits merci de me corriger tu
ferais mieux de tourner sept fois la
langue dans sa bouche avant de causer
toi je te le dire à aa si on arrive à
une élection présidentielle en disant je
n'ai que du sucre et du miel voici des
fruits des fleurs des feuilles et des
branches et puis voici mon coeur qui ne
bat que pour vous pour reprendre les
baux verts tout va bien mais c'est un
poème ce n'est pas la réalité dans les
rues de san francisco à un officier de
police se dirige vers la fenêtre
conducteur d'un véhicule qui circule
tout faisait 1 sauf qu'à l'intérieur la
personne dedans c'est fou le policier
surpris tente d'ouvrir la porte sans
succès il fait demi tour lorsque tout à
coup la voiture autonome repart seule
elle franchit l'intersection après que
le feu soit passé au vert et ce gars un
peu plus loin le long du trottoir des
jeunes qui retour d'une voiture de
police pour sauver les agents à bord un
geste de civisme salué sur les réseaux
sociaux à marseille le porte parole du
syndicat des commissaires de police à
partager cette vidéo sur twitter pour
remercier l'action d'une dizaine de
jeunes venus à la rescousse des
policiers piégés dans leurs voitures
lundi dernier le véhicule s'est retrouvé
sur le toit en voulant éviter une
collision avec un tramway la scène
cocasse poursuit les agents de police
rattrape la voiture désormais immobile
circonspect il tourne autour d'elle sous
les rires des passants ils tentent à
nouveau à plusieurs reprises d'ouvrir
les portes impuissants face à ce
véhicule sans conducteur contre lequel
ils ne peuvent rien je suis vraiment
super heureux de
rencontrer un chef sur massimo bottura
aussi un bon ba ba de moins en moins
th et habitants nous sommes sur rtl en
direct et sur m6 vous êtes marié bernard
veut je suis désolé bernard mais mon
deuxième nom et gaston lagaffe donc
kantienne à une affaire pour moi puis
alors on y va directement chez désolé